[Music]
the strike was necessary to protect and
defend u.s personnel in syria which have
been the targets of several recent
attacks by iran backed militia groups
[Music]
the us has no right to exist in syria
and the u.s government's military
operation against the syrian army
whether the regular one or other
organizations that support the syrian
army are illegal iran is reiterating
that washington's claims that some
syrian armed groups are attached to iran
are baseless and worthless
[Music]
hello the agreement can become
sustainable if all parties comply with
their obligations iran is now reviewing
and considering the text of the
agreement in hopes of taking another
step forward
[Music]
so
our commitment uh to push back against
iran's support for terrorism militancy
and the threats that they engage in
against our people in the region or
elsewhere are not linked to wherever we
end up on the nuclear deal